for
e
good afternoon uh ladies and gentlemen
um uh councelor Trisha Austin uh is on
her way but she's held up in roadworks
and having gone through seven sets to
get here myself today I I share her
pain I know but I had to go to the
Garden Center to drop me granddaughter
off and then get back oh struth one of
those
anyway uh fire alarm procedures fire
alarm procedures if the fire alarm is
activated vacate the offices via the
stairs please do not use the lists
assembly in hly square on the Green
officers will assist you and advise when
it's deemed safe to return to the
chamber uh would everybody please ensure
that their mobile phone is switched to
silence and they are not used to make or
receive phone calls whilst the Mee is in
progress
uh please note this meeting is being
live streamed for members of the public
the meeting is also recorded and will be
subsequently broadcast on the internet
does anybody intend to film the
meeting well what a
surprise uh FF no go to H uh officers in
attendance we've got Colin Carmichael
the chief executive uh Samira Khan
interim head of legal and monitoring
office Sarah Flack employee relations
lead and Nick Hughes committee services
manager and of course
Charles uh we have any
apologies but hopefully uh Trish will be
with us
soon uh does anyone have uh an interest
to declare at this
meeting no we're all completely
uninterested good uh minutes of the
previous
meeting uh please could I have a
proposer thank you David and Rick thank
you uh do we
agree agreed thank you
minutes of the extraordinary
meeting we
did David
and ah well you see you're not in my
seat of
power um minutes of the extraordinary
meeting uh to approved minutes of the
extraordinary meeting held on the 10th
of July 2023 copy attached in the agenda
pack please could I have a
proposer thank you Rick seconder thank
you David
do members
agree agreed thank
you um scheme of Officer delegation item
five uh Nick Hughes committee services
manager and Deputy monitoring officer to
introduce thank you
chairman so uh just to introduce the
report uh as part of the review by the
independent monitoring
officer excuse me it was recommended to
review the scheme of Del ation to ensure
that it's clear and easy to understand
and also include appropriate conditions
requiring engagement of counselors in
strategic and high risk decisions uh so
this paper represents one strand of the
work that we're doing to uh complete
this
recommendation uh the scheme of
delegations for cabinet and committees
was agreed at the annual council meeting
in
May uh as a result of that all other
decision-making powers that were not
retained by the cabinet or exercized by
committees were delegated to the chief
executive as head of paid service this
report demonstrates how the chief
executive has further delegated those
Powers down through the organization and
that's known as the scheme of Officer
delegations uh the chief executive has
then delegated those powers to the
directors of the council and in turn
each director has subd delegated to
their offices and that's all set out in
the uh in the annexes and that allows
for the golden thread of delegated power
to run from from the front-facing
officer on the on the street all the way
back through the chief executive to the
leader of the
council as I said the four elements of
the total scheme are outlined in the
annex is one to four of the agenda uh
and it's quite important to make clear
that the scheme of offer delegations is
in the gift of the chief executive as
the head of paid service it's not for
members to uh amend um but they can
comment on it um and as such the is for
information only so uh once uh after
today's meeting um we shall put the um
all four schemes on the council's
website to make sure that we are being
as transparent as possible um so if
anyone's got any questions I'm happy to
answer them thank you
Nick um any questions or comments from
uh
people uh I'll kick off um are we going
to have names
attached to these uh things because
reading through uh this morning I found
it very interesting that Ah that's where
I send uh that request
to you call in yeah there's uh there's
an organization chart which I thought
have been circulated which it impossible
to see on uh that screen is it right I
need to find way you need a screen that
big to understand it if I can remember
when I first started here in bit ago the
most frequent question I had from
councilors was can you tell me who does
what yeah um and there was no
organization chart or list of uh
officers against the post so we do now
have one which I probably need to do in
paper form and send around and that
would tell you at head of service level
all of the names of everybody um after
the restructure that we um carried out
in January uh Monday marks the final
appointment our new director of legal
will turn up on Monday and so all of the
officers will be in post and I can
circulate that what I think you're
probably asking for is below heads of
service so there'll be some sub heads of
service level so for example on Coastal
and public realm although um we have a
head of service underneath will be the
chief engineer the person managing the
port the person managing open spaces and
you're going to want to know who those
people are as well so um I'll set I'll
get one of those done and have those
round to thank you very
much
Sarah thank you so this is to review the
annual pay policy statement
um basically this is just an update so
we've updated um Chiefs officers and
deputy chief officers within the
statement and also we're looking to
reintroduce April pay increment subject
to when an employee starts so this was
previously in the policy before than it
had pay progression um pay for
contribution sorry um when that was
removed it the intention was that it
went back into policy however that was
never confirmed back in policy and it's
been agreed at CMT that that's that's
what we'd like to do so we're asking
obviously for that to go back into
policy so the reason we're here today is
asking you to adopt the policy subject
to a 30-day consultation with officers
we don't envisage any further
significant changes from the
consultation and they um and we would
like to implement this from
December thank
you
thank you I thought you writing names
down yeah thank you thank you chair um
just like to ask Sarah um the grades the
pay
grades um starts at
tgb can you tell me what happened to
TGA yes so with the
commitment of Bic to pay all officers
National living wage that one was eroded
due to the increase in the National
living wage um and that is something
that the council are looking to address
as
well um pedantic I know this is going to
sound right but at the end of the
reports we have a blank page that says
this page is intentionally blank well it
doesn't blank because it's got writing
on it
but could it wouldn't it not just to be
easier to put at the end of the report
end of report instead of having a blank
page to be left
blank if you see what I
mean but that it but you know it's the
same on any report it's not just this
it's the same across the
council y
absolutely I suspect this goes back to
the the days of printed documents where
you could
have a page number or
something anyway thank you okay thank
you
uh uh yeah I think unless I've
misunderstood there's a typo on page 15
so any payments reached under a
settlement agreement between the should
it be employer and
employee anex
one
on anex one you say
yeah payments will constitute special
Severance payments is the
first yes right yes of course
right
yeah we we'll get that
revers
and staff
um do I have a seconder if it's just for
adoption yeah thank you
Steve
uh do members agree agre agreed thank
you that concludes the business for this
meeting I declare this meeting closed at
1540 to thank you very much for
coming where do we
get